Hoy es el aniversario número 30 desde
que se instauró por primera vez el Día
Internacional de la libertad de prensa
cada año en France 24 hacemos el
análisis de las condiciones del oficio
de nuestros colegas En diferentes partes
del mundo y nos enfocamos en América
Latina que sigue siendo uno de los
lugares más peligrosos para elegir y
también para ejercer esta profesión
conectamos por ello con Arthur Romeo ls
director de reporteros Sin fronteras en
América Latina Arturo Un saludo para
usted y gracias por estar en directo a
América
con ustedes además por responder tan
prontamente nuestro llamado miren un
panorama mayormente ensombrecido hay
también algunas luces Por ejemplo el
hecho que ustedes resaltan de una
alternancia política que ha beneficiado
a los periodistas en dos países de
América cuéntenos sobre eso para empezar
claro por supuesto Bueno uno de los
datos importantes y casi sorprendentes
de la clasificación de reporteros Sin
fronteras sobre la libertad de prensa
este año es la alza de Brasil que tuvo
una alta de 18 posiciones en ese año en
relación al año anterior pasando la
posición 110 a la posición 92 nosotros
creemos no que que la la ese ese hecho
representa una expectativa no un
optimismo en relación a una Un regreso a
la normalidad en las relaciones entre el
gobierno y la prensa con la salida del
expresidente bolsonaro que fue un
mandatario caracterizado de un mandato
muy caracterizado por una violencia una
hostilidad permanente hacia la prensa o
sea No necesariamente el hecho la subida
de Brasil refleja a cambios reales que
ocurrieron durante el año pasado en
Brasil fue un año muy dramático para
libertad de prensa con mucha
desinformación año electoral muchos
casos de violencia el asesinato del
periodista británico Don Phillips entre
otros asuntos pero con el final del
gobierno se termina también una
pesadilla para los periodistas
brasileños entonces una expectativa de
cambio con la llegada del gobierno nula
y la demostración desde entonces de
voluntad política por parte del nuevo
gobierno de mejorar las condiciones para
el ejercicio periodístico en el país y
otro cambio que se ha visto Discúlpeme
para avanzar es Estados Unidos no
alternancia política
sí lo mismo pasa en Estados Unidos todos
conocemos la postura también la actitud
del Antiguo presidente Donald Trump
hacia la prensa no que caracterizó el
término incluso
para atacar a los medios
sistemáticamente no Entonces con la
llegada de un nuevo gobierno también
vemos ahí a nuevas esperanzas de un
regreso o de un fortalecimiento de las
condiciones para el ejercicio
periodístico a través de la
normalización justamente de las
relaciones entre el gobierno de Estados
Unidos y el periodismo pero tampoco es
tan sencillo no al mismo tiempo vemos la
fuerza que el ex mandatario sigue
teniendo en el país en términos de
reforzar y fortalecer un discurso anti
prensa en que señala los periodistas el
periodismo tradicional como una especie
enemigo público y la fuerza que ese tipo
de discurso sigue teniendo en la
sociedad
estadounidense Bueno y con alternancia o
sin ella la polarización es reinante en
el continente y esto sin duda tiene un
efecto propicia la hostilidad en el
ejercicio del periodismo y lo hace más
difícil pero también más peligroso Cómo
es que este fenómeno llega a dificultar
nuestra tarea
claro
uno quizás una los aspectos más
importantes de ese año en la región es
la baja de 33 posiciones del de Perú no
percibimos como durante todo el año
Durante los últimos años en Perú una
situación de grave turbulencia política
inestabilidad política muy muy
importante y con la destitución de Pedro
Castillo en diciembre pasado La ola de
manifestaciones que enfrentó una fuerte
y dura represión por parte del gobierno
con decenas de muertes y claro una
desconfianza generalizada por parte de
la sociedad peruana ante las
instituciones a políticas pero también
hacia la prensa no y y y alguna medida
una desconfianza hace un sector de la
prensa que es identificado Por una parte
importante de la población peruana como
más conservadora o asociada a los
intereses políticos y económicos de una
de las élites de Lima Entonces ese es un
escenario claro no de de inestabilidad
política y su efecto que puede tener
libertad de prensa en un país lo mismo
pasa por ejemplo en Haití que vive un
escenario de inestabilidad política
desde hace muchos años pero que se
agravó con la con el asesinato del
presidente en 2021 y se ha vuelto a la
crisis política en una crisis de
seguridad pública tremenda
casos de periodistas asesinados
solamente en el 2022 en Haití Entonces
el país se ha vuelto en los países más
peligrosos para los periodistas en
América Latina pero también podemos ver
ese tipo de dinámica no de polarización
en países que tradicionalmente son más
abajo en la clasificación de reporteros
Sin fronteras Como por ejemplo Nicaragua
que está en la posición 158 de entre 180
países en la clasificación de resev
justamente por estar siempre
manipulando el discurso de la
polarización para atacar la prensa o sea
de manera sistemática se utilizan del
discurso de la polarización del
imperialismo o o de otras de decir que
ellos son los enemigos hacer que están
asociados a determinados grupos
políticos y que deben de ser combatidos
a eso genera un escenario de persecución
permanente hacia el periodismo tanto por
parte del gobierno como por sus por su
base política hoy en Nicaragua por
ejemplo para ejercer periodismo
independiente si lo hace desde afuera
del país son cientos de periodistas
exiliados la mayoría en Costa Rica o en
la clandestinidad
mire me gusta que hable sobre Costa Rica
ya nos quedamos sin tiempo pero mi
última pregunta porque en ningún país
del continente americano está entre los
países donde la libertad para ejercer el
periodismo pues es mejor ni siquiera
Costa Rica que usted menciona que además
estaba siempre en los primeros puestos
de la clasificación mundial A qué se
debe esto y ya cerrando rápidamente por
favor
claro al Costa Rica De hecho está en la
posición 8 está en la última emisión en
la clasificación y ahora bajó de 15
posiciones está en la posición 23
es un ejemplo de una alternancia de
poder que tuvo efectos negativos o sea
el presidente actual o el nuevo
mandatario que llegó al poder el año
pasado llegó al poder como discurso más
crítico más hostil que reproduzca una
dinámica de ataques a periodistas con
campañas algunas veces de ataques contra
medios específicamente Y eso genera un
escenario de atención entre gobierno y
prensa y a peores condiciones menos
saludables para el ejercicio del
periodismo y la acción de los
periodistas en el país entonces creo que
aún sigue el país no con mejor
clasificado en la clasificación de
aeropuertos Sin fronteras pero ya hemos
que la tendencia señalada en términos
globales que de la utilización de la de
la propaganda de la desinformación de
los ataques y acoso en línea en contra
periodistas por parte de gobernantes que
recrudecen La La La La La La La La La
los ataques a la prensa se ha vuelto una
estrategia que tiene impacto no
solamente en Costa Rica pero también
Uruguay Argentina chile que son otros
países históricamente bien clasificados
en arranque pero donde esta tendencia de
manipular o de movilizar un odio a la
prensa como una estrategia política de
mantener a mayor control sobre el debate
político y la agenda pública por parte
de los gobernantes una tendencia que
desafortunadamente hacia se efectiva en
toda la región Arturo Romeo director de
reporteros Sin fronteras para América
Latina Muchas gracias a usted Gracias a
ustedes Ángela y pese a las malas
noticias o a las malas cifras continúa
el trabajo periodístico quédense con
nosotros ya volvemos con más de directo
a América
[Música]